so a way to show an awesome okay hi hi
it's a small groups or
questions interrupts me I had no idea
really what the mix of backgrounds would
be so this may be either to high level
or to low level I I'm actually coming
from LinkedIn where I've been for a long
time like the last seven years and I I
worked there on data infrastructure
primarily so I worked I worked on a
bunch of things from from kind of the
early days but it's been at least the
last three years pretty heavily focused
on the data infrastructure that kind of
ran the website and shuffled data around
a lot of what I'll talk about is kind of
ideas and systems that came out of the
problems we had there and I'll kind of
motivate those recently as was alluded
to I actually left LinkedIn I'm starting
a company which is actually related to
some of these ideas and I'm happy to
answer questions about that as well so
I'm gonna talk about a couple different
things I'm going to talk about the the
problem of data integration which is not
something people talk about that much
I'll talk about Apache Kafka which is a
system we built which is you know kind
of related and then I'll motivate kind
of why we built the system and the
problems it's useful for so let me start
with data integration this is my my
favorite problem a lot of people would
call this ETL so just so that I ground
myself people have people heard of like
ETL yeah everybody you know ok ETL
everybody knows ETL all right so this is
this will be an easy one all right so
ETL is you want to get a copy of your
data into your data warehouse and kind
of munch on it for analysis this similar
problem kind of exists all over the
place
and it's it's actually one of the bigger
problems for for any kind of large
company running a bunch of different
systems is putting everything together
and making sense out of it and it's a
problem that I kind of fell into without
a lot of understanding and I'll talk a
little bit about why I think it's
important this is Maslow's hierarchy I
guess no business presentation is
complete without Maslow's hierarchy I
don't know how many people have seen
this this is supposed to be some
hierarchy of human needs you know
starting with your physiological needs
like food and water and moving up to
kind of like self-actualization and the
respect of your peers or whatever and
the point of this IR key is when you
when you are lacking food and sleep and
safety you don't care about anything
above it and so my belief is you know a
lot of the use of data like there's a
lot of companies that are struggling to
use data effectively
there's kind of like big data movement
nobody knows exactly what that means but
it has something to do with collecting
you see there's some kind of similar
hierarchy the base of this pyramid is
actually being able to kind of capture
an instrument what is there the next
thing up is you know what the hell does
this mean like are we able to keep track
of what all these fields mean and then
everything above like understanding
automation like we eventually you know
had a bunch of sophisticated processes
that LinkedIn that predict people you
might know or you know come up with
similar profiles or whatever but all of
that is is built on like you know
actually having the data and being able
to make sense out of it and you know as
I spent time in this area I found that
there was more and more problems down
towards to the bottom of the pyramid and
I think the further afield you go kind
of in the world the more that's true so
a lot of people are you know very
interested in who are kind of getting
into this big data stuff they're very
interested in kind of you know how can
we apply deep learning algorithms to do
whatever and they basically don't have
any reliable data flip anything to you
and of course the algorithms do not
produce correct results when fed and
corrected that has remained true in
computers so the reason that this
problem has gotten harder you know the
reason that's not solved out of the box
is really two things so first of all you
know companies are interested in new
types of data so if you were to ask a
company what their data was you know
maybe a decade or so ago they would
basically go through their database
tables right so they would say well
we've got a user's table we have a
products table we have orders this is
our data the set of things that people
consider data that's valuable about the
businesses expanded dramatically that
includes a bunch of things you would
call event data so for a website that's
clicks impressions pageviews whatever
but you know almost any kind of business
has some events about what's happening
not all of which are represented in the
current state of your database tables
and then you know this kind of machine
data which is you know again for the
website use cases application metrics
you know what is the CPU load across all
these servers and a data center and
application logs this is again you know
kind of events for machines and so that
you know the problem with these types of
data is are much larger and you know the
more traditional data systems was not
built to address them the second thing
is really the
systems right so these are things which
are at LinkedIn that we were running
these are kind of our primary data
systems that we made heavily use heavy
use out of it's different for each
company but there there's kind of a
multiplication of these things hopefully
at some point there'll be some amount of
contraction but but nonetheless it's
pretty diverse so we had some things
that were basically key value stores we
had something which was a kind of
distributed graph engine that would
answer queries about who's connected to
who and what are the paths between
people
we had an analytical store that would do
that kind of like you know real-time
reporting like counting things basically
we had a search system which is how you
search for people and we had a whole
kind of you know real time monitoring
layer then we had the offline world
which was mostly Hadoop and Terra data
and as these systems started to evolve
this is kind of the world we started
ending up in so you have these different
on the top different sources of data at
the bottom these are kind of different
destinations for data and very slowly
you start to kind of piece together
these pipelines that ship data from one
thing to the other and as you get to
some scale each of these lines actually
gets a little bit complicated right the
data volume becomes large you're
potentially shipping data around the
world right because you're operating out
of multiple physical locations there's
different kind of requirements typically
you know data warehouse is more of an
offline you know load of data whereas a
lot of these other things are much more
real-time and you kind of get to this
full connectivity where you have
something on the order of you know N
squared pipelines that you're building
between systems to shuffle data so that
you can say search your logs and search
the you know people on LinkedIn but also
get that same stuff into Hadoop and and
that becomes this kind of increasing set
of complexity where every system kind of
ends up you know knowing a little bit
about every other system and the the
solution we came up to you know we came
up with for this it's really a kind of
central log and I'll talk about this
this idea where everything you know kind
of gets represented as a series of
changes in this log and these changes
are each you know kind of structured
record and so everything in the business
is in some sense a series of structured
changes and so that would that would
cover at LinkedIn that would cover
everything from
you know the pageviews that were
occurring errormsgs and different
applications in the data center if you
restart our machine they that's a that's
a message changes to databases and that
stuff would flow out into search indexes
it would flow out into the monitoring
systems it would flow out into real-time
processing systems it would flow into
Hadoop where you can run kind of like
you know big batch jobs on it and became
this kind of central you know
distribution point and that system that
kind of handled all that that log box in
the middle
it's called Kafka and so I'll talk a
little bit about what it is and kind of
where it came from
you know we it's a little bit hard to
describe where we basically implemented
a kind of distributed log we call it
usually a messaging system because
people are more familiar with that as a
you know genre of infrastructure so you
know at a high level you have this
cluster of machines which is acting as
kind of a middleman and you have you
know producers which are people sending
a stream of messages you know publishing
messages you have consumers who
subscribe to that data and you would
organize it you know we would say by
topic so you might have you know page
views is one you know big stream that
people are subscribing to and for a
while this was kind of alone as a weird
infrastructure thing but actually Amazon
and some of the other cloud service
providers have have created similar
systems to offer kind of as a service in
the cloud so if you're in Amazon you can
use Kinesis is pretty similar actually
down to the API staff guys so it's
becoming almost a class of things and
yeah I can talk a little bit about how
we how we got here how we how we came up
with this idea and how the
infrastructure evolved so you know like
I said we were we were kind of starting
down this path of building these custom
you know pipelines I was managing one of
the teams that was building one of them
which was really for the Hadoop cluster
and I was managing another team that was
building another one which was for this
key value store we'd made and so it was
just kind of weird that we were hiring
people to shell they had two different
parts in there they're kind of doing the
same thing and at the same time we had
kind of increasing requirements to be
able to do processing of data more
real-time right so come you know stream
processing or reacting and computing
things quickly and so that was how we
thought well you know instead of having
three projects we should probably try
and combine these in some way and come
with the central feed and we went
through a series of you know kind of
trial approaches where we we got
different messaging systems and we we
kind of benchmarked them and we would
like fork off some of the production
traffic and try and run it against it
and see if that would work and we
thought well you know they weren't
really designed for this kind of thing
and in particular almost nothing was
designed to be able to feed into an
offline system like Hadoop right so so
in the Hadoop case you know that that
system may go down for a period of time
and come back after maintenance you know
in the meantime your buffering up
everything that happened in some
large-scale web company to feed to it so
none of our solutions worked and then we
started down the you know slightly crazy
path of like making our own messaging
system that would you know hopefully
share some of the properties of the
different ad hoc solutions we had
because each had hoc solution was good
at least one thing so you know some were
reliable at delivering data somewhere
the latency somewhere high-throughput
you know they each had to nail at least
the one problem that they were there for
and we thought well you know it must be
possible to make these things work
together and the basic design principles
we had was you know first of all one
pipeline to rule them all we wanted to
take the union of these requirements and
try and put them together instead of
making things you know a bunch of ad hoc
kind of bubblegum and up cake duct tape
solutions we try and make one thing that
was good that was both durable and and
you know high throughput and low latency
second of all we wanted it to be a good
basis for processing not just shipping
data around so very often it's the case
you have to transform data that comes
around that's like simple if you can do
all your transformation is a single
process but if you have to be able to
split the processing up then you need
some kind of partitioning model and and
so on and finally you know we wanted
something that was managed as a cluster
right so I guess you know kind of nature
of modern systems is you want to kind of
think about it right to it operate it
configure it as a cluster rather than as
an individual machine like you would
with like you know my sequel database
where you kind of tune one database and
then another application has another
database
you know much nicer is something where
you can think of like a distributed file
system you don't really think about
which machine you're writing to and that
makes it obviously much easier to run at
scale and so what that meant we had to
was you know we we have to be able to
provide scalability kind of like a file
system because if we wanted to replace
these logging use cases usually the way
people are doing logs is they write it
to the file system really quickly and
then they kind of ship this log off
somewhere eventually so if we wanted to
replace that use cases had to be fast it
had to be efficient in terms of
megabytes per second we had to have
guarantees that were you know good
enough to handle the database updates
that we had in other words we had to be
able to guarantee that if you update
your profile we wrote into the database
that that that update would get shipped
into the you know the data warehouse or
the search system and it would get there
didn't have to get there all in one
giant transaction but it has to get
there pretty quickly and it has to get
there I can't remain permanently
inconsistent so that meant we have to
have some guarantee around both the
ordering of updates and then also not
losing updates in the system and I
already talked about you know making it
distributed by default which means you
know having a partitioning model having
replication among servers so if you do a
write and a machine fails you don't lose
your data this kind of stuff is just
really required to make a system like
this operable right you need to be able
to go in and restart machines and not
worry too much about what's happening at
the application level while you're doing
that and so over over time this became
heavily used at LinkedIn at any given
time there's you know something I'll cut
this is a little older but there are a
couple hundred terabytes of in-flight
data that's kind of being shipped around
we replicate between the different data
centers that we serve out of and the
offline data centers where we would have
Hadoop and this kind of batch warehouse
processing the the load is pretty high
both in terms of reads and writes and
you know the there's tens of thousands
of processors that are connected to this
that are publishing or reading messages
all right so so that's kind of Kafka let
me talk about kind of why what what what
the abstraction Kafka presents is and
you know how it comes into play in our
usage so so what Kafka provides I said
there's kind of a log and so I guess I
should start and kind of explain what a
log is many people may already know this
it kind of depends if you have a system
see background or not you know I guess
most programmers when I talk to them
if you say log they think really like a
text file with a bunch of updates in it
I guess that is a log but but I mean it
more in the kind of commit log sense of
a structured ordered list of records
that have been appended in some kind of
order and so this is the abstraction
that the Kafka provides it's basically a
series of changes you know you are
always appending to the end the records
are immutable they have some kind of
sequence number that identifies them and
you usually read from the left to the
right obviously left to right it's kind
of a made-up thing but we'll say it's
left to right and then because we are
kind of having lots of logs right one
for pageviews and one for changes to
this database and one for errors and and
so on and because some of those we're
going to want to scale quite a lot we
actually provide a partitioning model so
so at LinkedIn every page view you know
there's a topic called page view which
is actually made up of a bunch of
partitions each partition is a lock all
right so that's that's the abstraction
that the Kafka prevent provides most
people don't I also said it was a
messaging system most people don't think
of logs as a way of doing messaging but
they are actually not a bad way of doing
messaging you can think of the the
publisher or the data source as doing
rights which are appending to the log
and then you can have any number of
processes which are reading and you can
think of each of these readers as being
caught up at some point in time right
and time here is really just this
deterministic sequence number that we're
keeping with the law and so if you go
back to our horrible picture with all
those different systems all subscribing
to each other you can imagine how you
can use something like this each of
these you can reason about how caught up
is that system what time is it up to for
a bunch of different data sources so
I'll go through you're not depending on
people's backgrounds I'll go through a
simple example of how logs are used in
systems and kind of give it at least an
analogy to how we use these in some of
the systems that are running at LinkedIn
in order to kind of motivate this
example I'll give kind of how to make a
fault-tolerant hash table since this is
a popular thing and to make a concrete
will will keep CEO names in our hash
table
so you know to motivate this example I'm
basically trying to do a series of
updates and I want you to kind of you
know end up with this final state which
is you know the for each company name
what's the CEO right and if I'm doing
this in a single process is obviously
very simple if I'm doing across machines
it's more complicated and so I'll go
through kind of how can you keep to two
machines in sync off of off of this
sequence of updates and so an easy way
you know one of the easy ways is is a
log right so if I if I log each of these
updates to my hash table I can feed
these against both replicas I can reason
when I'm querying what's the state of my
hash table how caught up is it so I can
reason about how visible my data is if
one of these fails it can kind of replay
that log to come back into shape and so
this starts to address some of the
problems of distribution this is not a
new idea this is a very old idea that's
existed in systems for a long time the
only difference I think is now in
addition to using it as an
implementation detail of systems we're
also using it kind of in the large where
you have some central commit log that's
applying to these external systems that
are replicas of data as it happens we
end up also using this internally as a
way of building our system so that our
search system and our social graph
system we have a bunch of these kind of
data stores they're actually built in
this way as well right each of the nodes
is subscribing to some of these
partitions keeping a local index it's
good for certain types of queries and
then answering queries against that yeah
yes I mean I guess this is how you are
how you are maintaining reads and writes
across replicas so reads you know maybe
if it's our hash table example let's get
this is this is kind of how you can use
a log to to provide you know some kind
of consistency guarantees over machines
okay so now let me apply this back to
the this data integration problem let me
give a concrete example one of the
things linked it has is jobs so there's
a bunch of jobs on the website you when
you start out the logic for just
my job is very simple you kind of get
the job out of the database and you show
it to the user but over time actually
what most companies do with with live
data becomes more sophisticated and your
display of a job actually it gets a lot
more complicated in this example I
actually think I gave a subset of the
total set of things that happens when
somebody views a job so that set of
things would be well we monitor this
right so if our job views is important
if that drops we want to know if
something is bad we do recommendations
for jobs we recommend them to people and
so you know we actually keep track of
what's the click-through rate or the
application rate for individual jobs so
we can say oh this is a good match for
this type of person so that system needs
to know whenever somebody views a job
we provide analytics to the people who
post jobs so we have to be able to show
them like hey you know you posted this
job this is number of people who looked
at it for one of our much money you
spent there's a security team which kind
of analyzes all this type of activity to
make sure we're not being scraped or
spammed or abused so anything that
happens there is going to get analyzed
and finally there's kind of a data
warehouse and so so you can see like
this is one example of that data
integration problem each of these
systems has to be updated if the system
that was responsible for displaying
drops had to update all those systems
and doing so correctly and making sure
you have the same information available
everywhere it gets very complicated the
way in practice they do that is they
would you know they would publish an
event it contains all the information it
says hey a job View occurred this is all
the information about the job view this
is a time it happened this is a job that
was viewed this is a person who did it
this is what you need to know and all of
these other systems subscribe and apply
that change and so you can kind of see
this is this is similar to that you know
logs inside a distributed system but
it's not actually across a bunch of
system so you can think of this as a
kind of central commit log for the data
center or wherever where your journaling
out updates and you're applying those
across different systems and I would
claim that this is actually a lot better
than what most companies do for data
transfer so depending on how much people
know about that it's sort of the dirty
secret of how large companies ship data
around you know it's mostly a bunch of
like CSV dumps are syncing files around
you know a periodic job just kind of
it's
kind of a murky murky thing to reason
about whether it works or not the
advantage here is you know okay first of
all it's real-time so you you get
updates quickly it can be I think
compared ibly high throughput to the
kind of file copies people are otherwise
doing and you can kind of reaction
process at the rate you want you can
also you know do it in batch and do a
batch allotted into a data warehouse so
it has the same kind of advantages I
think of an offline ETL cycle while
allowing faster stuff so finally I'll
talk about one of the the things that we
also got out of making all of our data
available as a real-time streams which
is stream processing right this is kind
of the ability to react to each of these
streams and compute something on the fly
so you know it's it's kind of an
interesting question why more things
aren't done this way I can give kind of
one example from our experience which is
when I first got to LinkedIn a pretty
cool company called true vzo came and I
think this was based out of maybe
Telegraph CQ or one of the earliest
stream processing systems and and they
came to sell us a stream processing
engine and we were we were actually
pretty enthusiastic we said okay this is
really cool we're gonna use it and at
that time when I had for a scheduling
thing we had no real-time data so we
took the system we were like really
looking for anything we could hook it up
to that we could run real-time queries
against and of course we found nothing
you know the best the best we kind of
come up with is we can take our hourly
log files and we could you know feed
them into the stream processor at the
end of it at the end of the hour but
then we spent a bunch of time and we we
built Kafka we got everything going in
real time and then actually it became
very pressing once all your data is
available in real time you want to
process it in real time and I think this
is actually a fairly general thing about
how companies operate so this is the
first US Census and if you ever if you
ever talk to a software engineer about
the census one of the questions they
have is like why do they just go around
every ten years and count everyone like
going door-to-door why don't they just
like journal the births and deaths and
count all the time but it actually makes
sense why they don't do it that way
right when they started doing censuses
they were doing it on horseback you know
with large buying
so you literally had to kind of do this
batch collection and I think this is
actually not a bad metaphor for how a
lot of companies IT situations started
where you have a bunch of systems that
are kind of loosely connected you're
kind of periodically shipping data out
over you know finicky networks as things
become more digital as there's less
people involved I think it's much it's
very natural that that large clump of
data that's dumped periodically gets
smaller and smaller and you end up with
a stream that you process my view of how
this works is pretty shaped by what we
did it LinkedIn which is basically we
take these logs we apply jobs that that
transform the feeds and produce new logs
of changes and so we ended up with a
pretty rich ecosystem of things that
were taking these feeds of activity that
we're happening transforming them you
know counting filtering whatever and
producing new feeds of transformed data
those transformed feeds of course would
get fed into all the other things that
data fed into so like drive serving
indexes the the offline Hadoop cluster
the metrics and graphing systems so this
becomes kind of the transformation layer
and that big interconnected picture and
you know what I what I talk to people
about this there's there's kind of a
perception that stream processing is
kind of this weak niche you can't quite
get the right answers it's all you know
kind of approximate and actually that's
not true
you know the the stream processing
frameworks are out there today are a
little bit immature but there's no
particular reason that this model of
computation has to be much weaker than
the batch model so actually you know it
is actually possible to move a lot of
the things that happen kind of on a
daily cycle in companies to be much
faster you can get correct results you
can you can handle all of these things
the fact that it hasn't all been done
that way it doesn't mean it can't be
done
and the the example is where this is
particularly compelling for a website
like LinkedIn is really monitoring this
is kind of how do you keep track of what
the heck is going on across all these
computers and different business metrics
and why is it working or not working
anything around security you know these
are both domains where you want to react
very quickly
content processing you know if you if
you kind of go in and update your
LinkedIn profile we go in and we try to
figure out okay you said you worked at
this company is that correct
maybe that maps to this you know
standardized company that everybody is a
part of kind of all that data
normalization a lot of the
recommendation systems especially
anything that's dealing with
click-through rate data the kind of
newsfeed of updates that come in and
tell you oh these are the people who
change jobs and finally some of the
processing that happens as part of the
ETL pipeline so all of these are
actually pretty naturally suited to
lower latency stream processing versus a
kind of daily batch cycle and there's a
couple of frameworks that are out there
that can help
there's storm and we worked on one that
was called Samsa both of these are
pretty well integrated with Kafka so you
can you can take these feeds and kind of
transform them and produce new outputs
the way Samsa works it's basically a
layer that works on top of Kafka and
yarn which is kind of part of the Hadoop
ecosystem and allows you to kind of run
the processes across lots of machines
you you have a cluster like this you can
run a bunch of jobs that are doing these
transformations and producing data back
out to Kafka and using that you get this
kind of you know integrated architecture
where anything that is kind of produced
as data comes into this kind of central
log the stream processing can transform
it into some other log you can get kind
of monitoring or warehousing or key
value storage on top of it you can index
it in your search system etc you get
this kind of very well integrated
picture and that's what I had that
that's that's basically the kind of
Kafka Samsa pitch there's a more
detailed write-up on this there's also
actually I think they turned it into an
O'Reilly book if you want to kind of
dive into more details I also in that go
into more details on you know how you
can actually build the kind of drived
serving systems we had off of these log
structured data stores so you know if
you're interested in that that's kind of
a niche for people who are interested in
building distributed data systems but
that has more details on it and I'm
happy to answer whatever questions
people have
yeah so when you talk about real kind
yeah multiple producers cadavers yeah
how do you make sure that the streams
gets consumed when they keep them buried
a lot to say opinion right and where
would this data before it in somebody
just it's much slower than okay
yeah so the question is let's say you
have many many people producing data and
then you have different consumers that
are operating on different timescales
like one is very caught up and the other
is very far behind what happens to the
data that does not yet consumed how does
that get buffered yeah so that's
basically what Kafka does it basically
acts as this giant buffer so you know
what when it let go no no so let me talk
a little bit I've got a glossed over how
actually works cuz this is more
like a how to use it what is it good for
which is maybe the more important
question the way the way it works the
way cocktail works is it you know it
literally maintains a log file on disk
okay so every time I write come say that
writes it to this log file and that log
file is replicated across machines so so
when a rat comes in it writes it the
right replicates we acknowledge back and
say oh we got your right and so so you
know like the amount of buffering space
you have in a cocktail cluster is the
tone of this space of all the machines
divided by the replication factor you're
using for your data so if you're using
replication factor 3 and you know maybe
you get five terabytes per machine if 10
machines and you got 50 over 3 terabytes
of buffer space and so yeah in fact not
only do not all your consumers have to
be totally caught up you can have
consumers like a warehouse type consumer
that just pops up once a day sucks down
the daily BTL load should you choose to
run your ETL on a daily cycle processes
it and goes on its business and that's
actually kind of one of the primary
things you need it actually turns out to
also be really important for stream
processing the reason being ok you would
think stream processing it's all real
time they should all be caught up yeah I
mean maybe right but this is a company
full of people working somebody's thing
kind of breaks down or
and can't keep up you can't have
everything kind of backing up backing up
and the whole data flow processing graph
grinds to a halt because one guy you
know checked in a bug so that Bufferin
capability is extremely important
company whiskey okay what's the data
generationally
yeah that's a good question I think I
had some stats which may be slightly out
of date but I think we were claiming we
had about 175 terabytes of in flight per
day so that would be 175 terabytes of
new updates or whatever and I think that
that is probably the compressed number
pre-replication I guess if you multiply
you count each right three times then I
guess it's bigger size yeah it actually
varies a lot so some of the records are
very small they're just a few IDs like
this person did this thing at this
timestamp data and all the things are
normalized so you just refer them by ID
and it's very tight we're using
something called Avro which kind of
helps shrink the data down other things
are actually these incredibly large
records with lots of key value pairs
describing all kinds of context around
what was happening so it totally depends
on the type of data so for example
application error logs tend to be very
verbose with like huge error stack
traces and error messages and whatever
other things tended to be very small
it's totally it's basically this is an
open system so in the end there was
actually probably well over a thousand
of these topics of data created by
different people and so it kind of is
whatever whenever somebody put their
yeah so yeah the question is like what
kind of normalization is there for data
the
it is usually convenient to write stuff
is usually buy IDs usually whenever
you're working with it and when the
applications you have the ID so you have
a user ID maybe a job you have a job ID
a geography has an idea everything has
an ID right so you would probably be
writing out those IDs if you want to get
back any more attributes about that
thing you have to join it on which is
what people you have what happens in the
stream processing layer or offline and
Hadoop very commonly yeah yeah this is
actually an interesting design point so
it's very common that there's a lot of
debate so the people who process data
they typically want you to add
everything in for them so that the food
has everything the people who generate
data usually don't want to do that
because it's slow a big pain in the butt
and so there's some debate over what
what makes it into the event and what
does it I'm not sure what the right
answer is I mean I think if you find
yourself like we had situations where
someone would be like querying the
social graph to find out distance
information to figure out some distance
to put in the logging event that's
probably not really required you're like
slowing down the site right like
probably that should be done offline so
so I guess usually the principle is do
not line if you can but sometimes
there's things that are just so
convenient for analysis you might as
well just stick it in I don't know that
there's a hard and pastoral other
questions to understand the size of this
cluster with so many greets and writes
yeah yeah second with the latency or one
point yeah no I think the latency I
should say that this is a mixture of
observed and performance test data the
latency is probably more a performance
test result the actual observed latency
depends on three things
it depends on the buffering in the
clients it depends on what data center
you're in because we replicated
synchronously between data centers so it
depending on the amount of buffering it
can be higher that's really just the
time it takes with no buffering to do a
right have it replicate out to two
replicas and have the the consumer
process together this is what he does
need to liquid-cooled oh yeah yeah I
think the the size data is probably
overall and I think that the the writes
and reads per second I think
probably also overall I don't I don't
think those are per data center but
obvious that were running deposits of
no-no-no so um yeah okay question is how
big how big is the copper cluster so I
guess you know we we had two things that
were usually actually pretty closely
related one is Hadoop and the other is
caca the reason they're related is
because everything that went into Hadoop
pretty much came from Kafka but they're
not the same size and the reason they're
not the same size is because Kafka is
I'm just keeping data by default for a
week and then some people would set it
to longer so that they could replay off
of that but it's not keeping it forever
whereas Hadoop was keeping two years
retention and that pretty much
determines the size it also determined
the processing model is also really
different right a stream processing
engine is much more efficient it mostly
just keeps up with the live stream so if
you process a year's worth of data in a
stream processing system you do it in a
year if you process a year's worth of
data in a batch system usually trying to
do it as quickly as possible and so the
number of nodes in an offline system
ends up kind of ballooning up because of
that and so like alright I think we had
thousands of Hadoop machines total Kafka
footprint was like maybe 300 machines
but by no means the reason for that was
like we would have a cluster for each
acquisition because they're in different
data centers and then we segregated
operational data from business data and
so that led to different clusters and
then you need a cluster and so like it
kind of counts up but you know like
probably the individual sizes of the
clusters was like 20 or 30 notes
something like that they're not they're
not huge so essentially it's handling
maybe a hundred thousand messages per
second yeah that's probably that's
probably reasonable if you think about
it this is like a throughput oriented
system so it's pretty easy to get good
throughput like a hundred thousand it's
not really that much when you can only
multiply it by bytes and turn into chaya
yeah I read your blog that you're using
it on the real hardware instead of
virtual machines
what the performance implications are
that you found yes sir
so the question is you know you guys are
running this on real machines kind of
why and what are the performance
implications so we you know LinkedIn is
not in AWS so we run everything on real
machines we have systems that kind of
deploy software out to everything so
that I guess there's some level of
elasticity on the machines you have but
there's no like you know KBM or Zen or
something layer in fact it doesn't
really make sense within a company that
you would need that like virtualizing
the OS you kind of are all using the
same LS at a certain point yeah you
realize though we're running 20 of these
yeah I don't know so so yeah the
question is I guess there's a couple
ways you could ask it like one question
you could ask is why isn't it LinkedIn
and AWS
another question you could ask is just
kafka work well in that virtualized
environment it's a bunch of four things
I mean basically at a certain scale you
kind of want to pay attention to
efficiencies and you can probably do it
cheaper yourself
I guess linked is probably at that scale
at this point I know we did some cough
stuff and it was basically cheaper is
just built that way but they put me they
have machines and they carve out certain
chunks of it you know the machines are
just so big
yeah it doesn't make sense to just
leverage a full machine for it yeah one
node tow and so the question is
basically at what point if you did yeah
and you see that it may just make sense
to go onto real Hardware versus staying
on yeah yeah okay so I can answer that
both way so so LinkedIn and other web
companies they have the opposite problem
is what's typically solved by
virtualization typically virtualization
was like we have way more applications
than machines so we want to shove a lot
of applications onto one machine I think
most of the web companies actually have
the opposite problem which is I need to
actually scale applications over large
classic brucine so they're doing like
the opposite thing which is managing
applications over pools of hardware and
we have some internal stuff to do that I
guess so systems out now like musos
which are meant to be kind of
general-purpose solutions to that
the kafka will actually run quite well
on AWS I think there's a number of the
the biggest Kafka users are like Netflix
Pinterest whatever and are totally doing
it that way you do take some io hit in
with that type of virtualization but
it's it's not very large one of the
things we paid very close attention to
is since we're just keeping a log we are
doing really very simple linear i/o it's
kind of the simplest possible IO model
it works with old-fashioned spinning
rust discs and it doesn't you know
suffer terribly by virtualization they
seem to have some weird things like the
first time you write an AWS you pay some
penalty and whatever but so you
definitely take a hit but but it seems
to be totally fine to run the people who
run there don't seem to admit have any
big operational changes and how they run
it other than the interesting thing is
they actually choose to run much larger
clusters on smaller hardware because the
cost of losing one is less and I guess
you can so that was that was the only
major difference I I came up with from
looking at their setup than are key
questions so in your examples languages
I would say yeah so you're monitoring
insecurities which are also those nice
part of slow ok yeah that's right
attachment right so how would you
compare this solution yeah yeah ok so
this is the question is how does this
compare to spark which is a good
question yeah this is a much more
platforming approach so the good news
about this is it's like this open piece
of infrastructure everything can plug
into it's open source etc the you know
Splunk I think did a great job of
putting together an end-to-end pipeline
with a search engine on the other end
for really text logs right and they've
kind of brushed out two other stuff
I think the thesis I have is that this
kind of like a log or event data is
really an important thing and so the way
you get started of course is with a kind
of vertically integrated pipeline
mikesblog but I think the end result for
companies is they'll have something
that's more general-purpose that cuts
across different data sources and
plugs into you know more outputs allows
richer processing primitives and so on
rather than a you know proprietary
vertical pipeline time will tell yeah
yeah yeah I mean so I would describe
Splunk the questions about what's the
performance of Splunk versus koepcke I
mean caca is basically a log and so you
know it's very fasted hugging data if
you want to get a good performance
summary this is more like production
data but we did do a good performance
blog if you google for like Kafka
performance or whatever there's a
reasonable rundown of like okay with
different replication levels and
acknowledgement guarantees and so on but
Splunk focus is actually I believe been
more on indexing and search and so you
know unless you know a multi subscriber
log to fan out to other systems right
mostly they want you to fan it into
Splunk and they have some hook ups to
Hadoop and a few other things the so I
guess their performance is I think and
we were a long time ago we were we were
a customer of Splunk at that time their
performance was very driven by indexing
speed of their search component so I
don't know that would really make sense
to compare their search indexing which
is probably a much more expensive
operation with you know the fast cheap
logging that we do well my question
would be more than you know yeah yeah
yeah that's right that's right yeah
so an equivalent thing if you were
trying to make an open-source Splunk
like thing that would be something like
elastic search or solar which are the
kind of open source you know search
things very commonly used with logs and
Kafka would be a sort of data pipeline
for that good that recommendation engine
would be to do it on top of staining
versus offline yeah yeah I put
recommendations that's more a family of
different types of that
okay since then it is an application we
built a bunch of different
recommendation things and there's a
bunch of techniques that all work
differently so we had you know batch
algorithms that would recompute
periodically we had things that were
click-through rate based which I think
is the best match for this kind of
streaming stuff where you're looking at
what's popular now the that's really
probably the best fit for this kind of
streaming model is what's popular now
what's what's trending you know you
basically take the attributes of the
user review a pool click-through rates
or whatever by those attributes and you
do some modeling based on that to roll
it up the areas where that makes sense
is like ads news things where popularity
and freshness matter anything where
there's no freshness component it can
just be totally done offline so for
example we do similar you know profiles
if you go to somebody's profile it has a
long list I was something I worked on
all I'm trying to go that's totally done
offline it doesn't change that often
like people aren't becoming similar to
each other or just similar very quickly
so it gets recomputed like maybe every
day or something and there's not that
much value and making it faster website
but say a sequence of nuclear reactors
that are all you again have data logs
and error reports and the same sort of
things are different scale yeah possibly
I don't know anything about that so you
know something similar to this is
actually very similar in a lot of
finance companies like financial
services anybody who kind of comes into
it has to come into this real time
domain very often ends up with a similar
thing where you have some kind of law
and you have a bunch of things that feed
off of it and you have the replicas of
that so yeah I actually think it's I
think it's actually a pretty good
general way I've used a lot of like
social network examples because I know
them but but yeah I think it is pretty
general the things that have to be true
for this system to make sense as your
data has to be record oriented which is
not always true so if you have like if
your events are like genomes
they're probably pretty big they don't
really make census events this is really
like things happened the things are you
know records they're happening really
quickly our data model is like the world
is streams of records so if you don't
have records this probably isn't a good
fit and then you know you would have to
get some value out of the processing
things kind of as they occur versus at
least some scientific computing
applications maybe you just have a big
pool of data and you run some cool
algorithms on it and you get the result
but the data isn't really changing so I
don't know if it's it I don't know if
it's a good fit for that but yeah it
definitely has found usage in like a
bunch of non web companies so like
telecom companies finance companies and
so on go system like to see producer and
consumers we kind of standardize on the
bus yeah yeah confluence is the company
steward for open source and the dr.
sense or you see that going as the
Kinesis direction of top there's a
service yeah so one of the early things
you know I guess the question was what's
the company doing well I mean we're just
getting off the ground so we're starting
but another question was you know what
about all these different plugins to
connect different systems yeah being
able to make those work in a standard
way
have a common data model across them so
it's easy to plug things together that's
kind of like super low hanging fruit
thing we'd like to take her any other
question sir
did I hear company name didn't yeah yeah
the company name is confluent okay and
what was the motivation to start and my
first question when he came it was why
he was the company but question is why
is this a company yeah the answer is we
thought this was basically a much better
way of organizing your data than what
most companies were doing and we thought
it was not totally feasible to get
everybody in the world to do it via an
open source project oh you can kind of
get a certain amount of the way where
people who are very technically
sophisticated have a large team of
engineers to throw on and adopt things
quickly we'll do it and that's kind of
the state we're in now but to get the
rest of the way I think it actually
requires more money or requires more
support and so on so yeah so the mission
of the company is basically to make this
real time data stuff work right to make
you know the data flow and data
integration problem work this way
replace the kind of our synced batch
files make stream processing a
reasonable way to consume that data and
transform it into other things that's
what we're that's what we're trying to
accomplish and the reason for the
company is just because you can only go
so far on github I guess yeah yeah we're
not we're not looking to do any kind of
hosted kafka I think this naturally
lives wherever the rest of your systems
would live so if that's in the cloud
then you would run it in the cloud but
if it's if it's on-premise in your own
data center then it's all they know
you've got these problems we will make
solutions for even give them back to you
yeah that's right we're not really doing
heavy consulting we're gonna kind of
take this package and put together a set
of things that people can use you know
products services that jump up a bit
yeah
so you mentioned about stream processing
oh yeah so what kind of modules or
components - you went to state
yeah yeah you know I'm not sure we
basically just just announced the
company like a few days ago so I'm still
figuring it out question today busts
paper yeah I've been curious is that
yeah yeah it's actually so there was the
history of this is there was actually a
system before Kafka at LinkedIn it was
virtually identical in the abstraction
it it provided and it was called data
bus and the caveat on it was it only
worked with databases so it would
basically acted as a sort of cache for
whatever the database log was and and it
was used in this way and then basically
we liked that so much it was built
originally to feed like the social graph
and search so it was like very very very
straightforward we had you know
relational database we had a social
graph search system they each had a
bunch of machines they had to be fed
changes we built this like cache for the
log and we fed it out and then we were
like oh my god this is the best way if
he changes around everything we're doing
is basically feeding changes and in
particular we were interested in
extending that to event data you know
this is the page views and the clicks
and the impressions and that kind of
stuff which is much higher volume and
obviously there's no upstream log of
that tact as a cache for so so that was
what we made Kafka for originally it was
just used for that there's now kind of
expanding out to all the use cases that
were originally doodle but with the date
of us it was the idea that somebody
could bootstrap from ground zero
yeah so the that's a good question okay
so this is a nuance we had two systems
database and Kafka did Wes was the
earlier system one of the features of
data bus was it would allow you to kind
of go back to time zero and it would
kind of filter out redundant updates for
you and and that was actually very nice
you think well why would you want to do
that
turns out it's very useful if you have
something like a search system where you
have a bunch of nodes which are
subscribing to some part of the log and
indexing it if you lose
one of those news and they lose their
data the most natural way to restore the
data is actually just to say hey that
that news that time zero that's it's
time and it just kind of like plays
forwards and we indexes the and so we
actually do have that feature in Kafka
to be able to kind of prune obsolete
updates in a similar way we call it log
compaction and it's it's specifically
used for that because Kafka also takes
writes you can actually use that for all
types of interesting journaling of
computation use cases we use it in the
stream processing system to be able to
do stateful stream processing like
maintain counts and all of those updates
are journaled out so that the stream you
know the stream processing with one of
those instances fails it can kind of
restore itself from that log so actually
it's a very cool feature I didn't go
into it in detail here just because it's
hardware yeah ok so the question is I
think just generally high availability
how does it work right
ok so this is a fairly traditional like
master slave model so at any given time
you know the cluster has a bunch of
partitions maybe a thousand partitions
that cover all the different topics each
of those partitions has a leader and
some followers and the leader accepts
all the rights and determines the order
the followers apply those rights in
whatever order the leader determines if
the leader fails you elect a new
follower out of the set of followers
that are in sync and available for
election so you know the guarantees you
get out of that are you know your your
your non availability window is going to
be the time it takes to detect that the
leader has failed and then the time it
takes to react a new leader during so
you so whenever you know whatever that
failure happens you have a small window
of right unavailability usually for this
kind of system that's okay like
producer can kind of buffer and keep
writing as long as it's very quick where
you would run into larger problems as if
you had some kind of like persistent
network partition that mostly doesn't
happen to us inside of data centers very
often it has happened between data
centers but we would always run these
clusters in a data center and kind of
replicate asynchronously across and so
that that problem is less less of a
problem that is the kind of that you
know that's how the fault tolerance
works maybe your question is more like
what's important to run it and keep it
available yeah okay yes sir Kafka
doesn't do recharging you can add
partitions right but we don't do any
kind of transfer of data if you do so if
you have one partition and all your data
is in that partition you can add another
partition but then you have one
partition with a bunch of data on one
printer that's empty presumably your
rights will now distribute over those
two but we don't we don't reach all the
day that makes sense yeah after that so
so our model is basically an over
partitioning model where we say like
okay if you think you want to scale
eventually to 100 machines you know
hundred partitions now of course some
people are underestimated what they need
and then they do but but when that
happens you have to if there's really
two cases sometimes the partitioning is
used really just for scalability and
sometimes it's used as a semantic
partitioning where you're partitioning
by key and the stream processing system
that is subscribing is partitioning up
its processing along with that in the
first case it's easy right now you're
just distributing over more shards in
the second case it's actually hard and
recharging that data is going to depend
on the semantics of how you're using it
and that's something like you'd have to
participate in all right any other
questions back some of the things
you might get more widely accepted yeah
yeah so the question is what what's
needed in Kafka should make it more
widely accepted a couple things like
security like right now we don't have
any built-in security that's a big deal
the maturity of the clients outside of
Java there's a long tail of clients
really getting something that's robust
in every language is important so that
it works a lot of language people are
using and I think just the kind of
out-of-the-box experience like we've
done this as an open source project so
we kind of give you this pretty reliable
piece of low-level infrastructure but
everything to plug into all the rest of
the systems is something you would kind
of do yourself so there's a lot of work
now to actually adopt this in a company
and put it to use yeah so the question
is you know is there coming in to do
anything to make tooling for Kafka
easier the answer is yes probably but
that I don't think we know exactly what
it should be so which is more of a
stream processing angel cafes more of
you know login behind it so those are
two different that's a solution so I
guess what you are trying to achieve it
so visa would be very different from
what you can achieve with copper so what
was the vision around yeah yeah so I
gave this true visa example at LinkedIn
I was kind of trying to motivate why I
think the point I'm trying to make is I
feel that like step one for us was
actually making data available in real
time and then once you have that you
very much want to process in real time
it's very hard to process data in real
time if you don't have anything
available in real time that was really
the point I was making in this model
there's really two things right there's
a kind of real-time stream and then
there's like a processing engine which
would be the processing point in true
visa it's obviously more combined right
you could argue whether or not this
separation of the stream processing
layer and the
underlying log is good or bad but but
that is you know how it is the
processing layers people use commonly
are like storm Samsa which I talked
about and a little bit spark which has
some stream processing stuff all of
which integrate pretty well with caca
coal it's still a busy building these
large systems is still sort of it being
stage of trying to figure out what all
your pieces are then though they scurry
around and give up and various companies
in the valley and pick up tools and make
things when is somebody gonna figure out
system integration is it for large scale
systems as a product or as a company
mm-hmm okay so the question is it's very
hard to build you know these types of
large-scale systems I don't know if you
mean individual components or you know
your other person was more like
integration between components yeah yeah
so yeah I mean I think hopefully this
helps with some of the data integration
problems I mean what we found to be a
simplifying abstraction was being able
to take data across many different
things and make it available in a
uniform way right that obviously helps
there's other parts to that so like
there was a bunch of tools we had
specifically around building distributed
systems that's kind of of use to people
who are building distributed systems but
it's you know not necessarily as related
to the data integration problem so yeah
I don't know I guess I had this
discussion with a friend that maybe all
the hard problems are integration
problems because just the nature of
software is anything that's you know you
can turn into a reusable abstraction
you've done it so once you have all the
reusable abstractions all that's left is
yeah so maybe the nature of it is it's
all it's always going to be integration
problems it's just the type of
integration problem will change I don't
know cool question is data retention
very masking uses a 24-hour retention
yeah
times zero they apply given there's this
race to zero and stored drop box box and
various players you extrapolate out
storage for time you proceed with five
ten years we could infinitely retain
logs instead open up new machine
learning or that kind of corpus of data
yeah so the question is can is it visit
is it reasonable to infinitely retain
logs yeah the answer is yeah absolutely
the there's you know the retention is
configurable if you configure a bit to
infinity that it will stay forever
usually people don't actually want to
reprocess everything but but it can
actually be useful the model we've taken
is you know we we use Hadoop as kind of
the archival store for LinkedIn I think
most things just go back to years it
doesn't go back to the beginning of the
company you could argue whether that's
good or not and then we use Kafka really
for the stream processor for kind of
reprocessing in these stream processing
jobs and so there are some topics that
have much longer retention or use that
kind of heat compaction to give you a
complete snapshot for the stream
processor to be able to restore its
state so why would you want your street
and processor to go back in time the
answer there is usually like you change
the logic and the stream processing and
you want to compute it some different
way it has to kind of restart and
reprocess forensics on it for example
simply post back they're serving Sox
compliance retention for thirteen months
of longitude and every single system to
go back in retrospect and analyze the
laws and that's huge IT problems today
the student systems distributive laws
yeah so the question is like would this
be useful for an audit of historical
exact potentially I haven't heard of
that use case but but absolutely site
becomes huge is there some kind of
compression
yes sir carpet does have internally a
kind of batch or block compression that
compresses together records which is
very important especially for these
text-heavy records forgetting these
commercially around intubation and
largest own so these corporations which
have multitude of systems talking to
each other and individual connections
typically will have some meaty and tool
animal trying to transform and yeah that
occurs so how easy would it be for them
to replace that like this and and and
you know what kind of support will
confident be able to provide in that
regard to take that transformation which
comes with its own store as well yeah
black independent right it I kept what's
this yes I think the question is how how
good of a replacement is this stuff for
you know an ETL tool today thank you
answer is it kind of depends what the
ETL tools really do a good job of I
would say today is they have a pretty
rich GUI which allows you to kind of
model all the transformations and then
they kind of carry that out in their
system what this does I think a good job
of is or what we did a good job of at
least at LinkedIn what we'd like to make
you easier for other people who to do
what some companies have done is
actually do a good job of capturing
structured data capturing good metadata
along with your streams and again what
they're kind of like directly mirror
that in something I could do what we
found at LinkedIn was if you do a good
job of that you can actually replace a
lot of the more mundane data cleanup
problems because your data is well
structured to begin with you can get rid
of a lot of the manual work in data
loads because Hadoop is actually pretty
scalable so you can just have a rule
that's like hey everything that shows up
we load and we turn into a hive table we
use the metadata to create the hive
tables that doesn't get rid of every
type of transformation there's actually
a lot of high-value transformation that
happens later but it becomes subset
instead of it being the case that every
piece of data has transformation along
with it I think as if the stream
processing layers if these kind of open
stream processing layers become more
sophisticated I think it will be more
possible to replace all of it but to a
certain extent like transformation of
data is kind of the Mandate of almost
every tool in the Hadoop ecosystem like
there's like 47 transformation tools and
languages and so one you know critique I
have of ETL is like well Yi is
extracting how is load you know I pretty
mechanical T is actually like all of
programming and so you have to be
specific about what part of T you're
actually trying to capture all right
cool so now to take other questions that
people have them up here but but thank
you all so much
you